you know if the right person watches
this video something crazy can't happen
let me explain to your wife world cup is
finished with no one's watching it
anymore France won the World Cup right
and someone asked me so pad what was
your biggest takeaway from the World Cup
I said look you got seven billion people
that watch this sport
seven billion people we even got people
at the Home Office still playing soccer
and Arad is gone right seven billion
people follows a sport France wins the
whole thing think about it this way Luka
Modric wins the golden ball ballon there
or right and then you have embarked from
France who becomes the youngest player
teenager
since Pele to score a goal in the finals
which is insane but I want you to think
about it this way look at it this way
every sports magazine every newspaper
every internet website is going to write
about those two names Luka Modric
everyone's gonna know who he is M Bob a
everyone in the world knows who use a 19
year old kid is now hero that people
didn't know around the world what does
this mean to you look every industry
every decade has a new Imbaba say one
more time every industry every decade
has a new imbaba every industry every
decade has a new Luka Modric every
industry someone around the world today
has made a decision to be the greatest
realtor in that country
someone in the world today has made a
decision to become the best businessman
of that country for the next decade
someone in the world today has made a
decision to be the best actor the best
producer the best director the best
something someone's made a decision and
guess what they think about it from
morning till night they dream about it
they fantasize about it they sleep
writing about it all over the wall they
tell their families it's gonna happen
one day they tell themselves in front of
me what's gonna happen one day until it
becomes a reality everybody she the
right person watching this I said at the
beginning the right person watching this
your industry is looking for an embody
your industry is looking for a locale
you have an opportunity every decades
somebody rises up no one knows who it is
only the person that's going through
that process
no suitors if that's you you got to put
your head down get to work out work out
last out strategize out improve
everybody in the marketplace five ten
years later they're gonna call you
TM Bobby De Luca of your industry but by
the way as much work as you think it is
as much improvement as you think it is
it's ten times a lot of long nights
where everybody's home you're still
training you're still selling you still
working you're still getting better many
many nights like that but I can't wait
to meet the Amba pace the Lucas of all
these different industries in the world
hopefully it'll be you
[Music]